miner working in short slaves the number
23 on his back
david dahl first up lefty lefty changed
to a little bit more right-handed heavy
with the exception of
dahl and blackman and a chopper over to
first ronald guzman in there today and
he'll feed
minor for the first out of the ball game
miners 1-2
got him got that
high strike call on story and miner
can do some damage in that part of the
zone 2-2 again
hit back right by miner he's spun to get
out of the way as it rockets into center
field for a lead
a two out single first base hit for
20 20 for nolan arenado they saw some
pretty big improvements
blackman with a bloop out toward left
two coming on and he'll take care of it
two in the inning
john gray the big kid from shawnee
oklahoma now 28 years young
this ball is pretty well hit left center
field and
hampton leaps got it he caught it oh my
goodness
take that one back garrett hampson
who can play everywhere went over the
wall
at globe life what a play by hampson to
race back put the glove
above the yellow line and john gray on
the hill
clasped his glove above his head
and pointed out to garrett hampson wow
man that was exciting
man that was exciting
off the end of the bat a little blooper
that will be handled by chris owings
two outs extraordinary play two strikes
on danny santana and this is an easy
play for mcmahon
and john gray with uh some help from his
left fielder garrett hampson
2-2 man that is a nasty slider that's
the pitch that uh
most of the strikeouts in john's career
come off that slider nearly exclusively
last year that was a relationship that
was forged early on and
chris woodward respected it for the
better part of the season a swing and a
foul tip by hampson is strength three
swinging a miss his fourth strikeout of
the ball game
there it was again the change up at 86
miles an hour with some pretty good
movement
nothing nothing game with arenado at
third and blackman reaching on the error
as the rockies look to scratch something
out here in the
fourth reaches for it and flies it to
right moving in
is gallo and that is a fair ball
just inside the line aronado scores
blackman races over to third and matt
kemp delivers an rbi
single and the rockies are on the board
in the game and in
2020. they're gonna walk to the outside
corner again
[Applause]
in the middle of the diamond knockdown
they're gonna come home wild throws safe
at the plate ball gets away
and moving to third is camp mcmann will
go to second
two nothing colorado two on and two outs
and shinsu will get an opportunity here
two swings and he rips it just off the
first baseman's glove
that's a base hit kuzma in to score
mathis stops at second
and it's a 2-1 ball game and john gray
will have to depart
daniel bard the right-hander the power
pitcher at 6-4-196
will make his first major league
appearance since april 27th
2013. the rockies signed him during
spring training one and lo and behold
daniel bard
is back on a big league mound here on
july 25th
2020. glove at the chest the pause the
pitch
breaking ball hit the left room
plenty of room for hampson he's got it
and
daniel bard slams the door here in the
fifth on his return to the big leagues
you have to get this guy over there with
the top of the lineup coming up in the
seventh inning in a one-run game
there's david dahl the leadoff man oh
for three today left-hand batter
next pitch to dahl swung on hit the
other way and that's going to go into
left center field for a base hit
hampson trots in from third and the
rockies build the lead to 3-1
on the rbi knocked by david dahl so they
are loaded
and now some legitimate pressure being
put on the rockies
danny santana coming to the plate here's
the one-two
god buried a slider and got a huge
strikeout but not out of the woods yet
because this is
in the air to right field charlie near
the line makes the catch and carlos
estevez works out of it
shoe and rbi single in the fifth also a
walk one for three
and this is popped up and playable right
side mcmahon coming down the line he'll
make the catch one out
[Applause]
in the air to shallow right blackman
coming on and
charlie will call off as he should chris
owings
out number two big full count pitch on
the way
gallow nubs that one down to third
that's a base hit andrew scores
and odor will get a shot three for 15.
that's the thing of beauty joey gallo
had no idea where that ball was he took
a monster hack
one and two with two outs strike three
called at the knees ball game over as
davis freeze or door and the rockies win
for the first time in 2020